l'élection du record absolu dimanche
dans l'isoloir les électeurs ne versent
devront trancher entre 7 listes soit 2
de plus qu'aux dernières municipales la
droite républicaine d'abord aurait pu en
faire qu'une de liste comme en 2008 mais
entre lui MP et l'UDI l'Union au premier
tour a échoué résultat l'opposition qui
part affaibli n'affiche en plus aucun
véritable leader exactement le même
scénario qu'aux conseil municipal ou
l'union à droite passe après les
ambitions le maire actuel lors d'un de
ces meetings
partisans a dit que le problème de
Guillaume ailleurs c'est qu'il avait
trop d'ambition moi je trouve que lors
de l'ambition en politique c'est
légitime je pense incarner une
génération active à Nevers qui se plaît
à Nevers qui aime cette ville
effectivement j'aspire à incarner cette
droite républicaine de demain si les
gens ont un petit peu de courage je
dirais et de volonté de changement il
est sûr qu'ils doivent voter en fait
pour et pour pour cette alternative
qu'on appelle salvatrice pour la ville
de Nevers
qui peut l'incarner parce que je pense
si vous voulez que dans toutes les
listes on est la seule à mon avis nous
sommes la seule liste de droite si vous
voulez à gauche aussi il y a du monde
pour barrer la route au RPS sortant de
liste celle du PRG et de Lutte Ouvrière
désireuse d'incarner la gauche populaire
et d'ouvrir grand les bras au dessus du
socialisme le Parti socialiste ne
Verseau n'est plus de gauche depuis bien
longtemps oui je le dis leur répète le
Martel et le cordon est coupé avec les
habitants et le peuple de gauche depuis
bien longtemps oui il y a une autre
solution pour les travailleurs il va
falloir se battre c'est pour ça je dis
le programme qu'on a c'est un programme
pour les luttes futures et les les
personnes qui qui voteront pour nous et
ben au moins ils marqueront leur camp
pour la première fois aux municipale à
Nevers une liste Front national tentera
de rallier les électeurs à son panache à
la présidentielle de 2012 le parti de
Marine Le Pen avait convaincu près de
16% des électeurs ne versoirs moi je
veux bien et ça me gêne pas trop que les
gens qui sont en colère les gens qui en
ont marre les gens qui veulent rejeter
le système actuel du MP le PS viennent
au sein du rassemblement bleu marine
s'exprimer via exprimer leur colère
parce que je pense qu'il n'y a plus
aujourd'hui que le Front national le
rassemblement bleu marine pour recevoir
pour écouter pour entendre la colère des
des Français qui sont mécontents et des
neversois ici dès cette liste en
présence en voici une qui fait le buzz
avec son bus Nevers à venir une liste
indépendante avec à sa tête et
d'ailleurs comme pour la liste FN un ex
militant PS déçu par les partis
politiques aujourd'hui les parties n'ont
plus de crédibilité et ils se sont
eux-mêmes tirés des balles dans le pied
quand on voit ce qui se passe encore
chaque jour les affaires à droite les
les maladresses des affaires à gauche et
très franchement aujourd'hui il y a des
villes déjà depuis six ans qui sont
gérés par des listes sans étiquette et
je peux vous dire que ça se passe très
bien donc nous sommes en mesure de
réaliser cela et c'est ce que nous
proposons une voie différente pour les
personnes qui se retrouvent plus
socialiste écologiste et communiste
partent groupés autour du RPS sortant
Florence And farguarnaud élu il y a 3
ans et demi par le Conseil Municipal
après la démission de Didier boulot
dimanche le jeune maire pourra mesurer
la solidité des liens de confiance
qu'ils pensent avoir qui sait avec les
noeuds vers soi durant ces trois années
ça m'a permis depuis 3 ans et demi de
travailler à lancer des dossiers c'est
le quai des mariniers sur lequel nous
sommes le nouveau musée de la faïence le
rugby la place de la Résistance donc
tout ça a été lancé dans la la dynamique
d'un jeune maire d'un nouveau maire les
neversois savent au fond à qui ils ont à
faire ils me connaissent ils connaissent
Alice sont des gens solides et fiables
donc il y a une confiance qui est
possible mais avec 6 adversaires en face
l'élection municipale à Nevers n'aura
donc rien d'un long fleuve tranquille
pour le Parti socialiste aux command es
de la ville depuis 43 ans autre source
d'inquiétude l'abstention qui elle aussi
pourrait bien s'inviter au tableau des
records aux municipales de 2008 plus de
4 électeurs ne versent sur 10 ne s'était
pas déplacé